and I close
[Music]
toni sharing to the title of top friend
sale of blue gold that we start the
week and I am asked I know the risk of life
over here oxa gas
a ride or on the galanzino cseh with
intensity
you want swan xamamina pulling out of the
rhythm of almost words core with  jean
health
[Music]
there and not
you will not deploy me go unfortunately
buy systems my next in the
square with lots of thousands below with
hitachi played posed by a deputy who,
however, I
am almond tree too I received hands we send
humanity and on
which his  name was not already seeing hands
[Music]
on the Adriatic city of with
but that after an ancient
no sorry so much I have to say it camera a lot of
curiosity all tactical minutes I may
like it that was more given these lines I have
already thought king mad and I ask
championship with the windows on the year is
already warned and gives a long
questioned you called ravera believers
that upsets me starts going never even
learned nichi in silence
an intense king way to r  or but they will not be
in fact we know the concept that we
rejected
[Music]